star wars rogue one pour la première
fois un spin off en films de star wars
et créé après le retour des sites dans
la galaxie
l'étoile noire est en création et chaque
planète peut être réduite à néant les
populations doivent faire face un groupe
de personnes se réunit donc pour lutter
face à cette arme et cherche donc à
voler les plans de celle ci l'alliance
rebelle et donc créé pour cette mission
c'est un nouveau personnage principal
créé pour la cda qui est envoyé au front
jean erceau et nous en savons peu sur ce
personnage
et cette nouvelle histoire et donc de
nombreuses théories sont évoquées sur ce
nouvel opus
et en voici trois que je vous propose
vous souvenez du grand-père qui meurent
au début de star wars 7 et qui donne le
morceau de cartes à pau damon et bien ce
mystérieux personnage dont on ne connaît
pas l'identité pourrait avoir un lien
avec star wars rogue one ce personnage a
l'air très important on voit dès le
début de star wars est comment un
personnage inconnu pourrait-il posséder
un morceau de carte menant à luc et
connaître autant la famille skywalker
je dois vous rappeler que star wars a
été racheté par disney est donc la
nouvelle trilogie et les prochains spin
off sont donc créés par disney et ils
ont tous les droits
ceci nous montre bien qu'il est très
fortement probable qu'il y ait des liens
entre les personnages et entre les films
tout simplement rentrons plus au coeur
de la théorie ce papy est connue sous le
nom de l'or san té ka pour ceux qui ne
le sauraient pas dans star wars rogue
one un nouveau personnage qui semble
très important apparaît dans la saga
il s'agit de galen marek d'après notre
théorie galen marek serait llorente cas
pourquoi même si disney a avoué zapper
complètement l'univers étendu il s'en
inspire quand même beaucoup dans
l'univers étendu galène marre
et possède un lien intime avec dark
vador car elle et son apprenti secret
dark vador a tué les parents du jeune
garçon et l'a pris sous son aile et en a
fait un site
cependant en avançant dans l'histoire
galène retourne sa veste et changent de
mentalité et repasse du bon côté et
rejoint même l'alliance rebelle mais
s'il rejoint l'alliance rebelle c'est à
dire qu'il connaît donc les ja ran et
l'udc
qu'est ce que je veux dire par là il a
très certainement tisser des liens avec
eux et c'est donc pourquoi il connaît si
bien la famille des skywalker donc
caille lorraine qu'il a dû connaître à
sa naissance puis cela expliquerait
aussi pourquoi il possède le morceau de
cartes clés menant à luke skywalker
il protège à cet artefact en vivant
comme un est remise sur la planète des
airs de jack nous pour que personne ne
la trouve galène serait donc l'or ça
n'est qu'un cri concord l'âge aussi car
même si galène semble plus âgé que luke
leia et ran il reste plus vieux que dans
star wars 7
je trouve vraiment cette théorie
excellente qu'en pensez vous cependant
deux choses me dérange l'acteur de
galène match amical scène n'a pas sa
langue dans sa poche et n'a pas pu
s'empêcher de ce pôle et certaines
choses dont le fait qu'il ne joue pas un
méchant puis disney change tout de même
pas mal l'univers étendu alors on peut
douter à propos de l'histoire du
personnage mais pas sur son identité
il est fort probable qu'il soit lorson
ces cas
le crash du sauvetage lego star wars
ta gueule
alors oui pablo a réfuté cette théorie
mais bon on peut jamais être sûr à 100%
avec les créateurs qui nous dit que l'on
nous ne cache pas la vérité donc je m'en
tape
ce ne serait présent dans star wars
rogue one et serait dans une cuve de
bacta de guérison pourquoi tout ceci par
à la base d'un trailer de rogue wave où
nous voyons un être encapuchonnés
s'agenouiller devant un grand tube blanc
la plupart des gens ayant vu le trailer
associerait ce tube blanc à une clique
de bacta dans lequel luc était dans les
anciens films l'etrat genouillé serait
alors dark sidious en personne mais
pourquoi ça genou irait-il peut-être
arseneault qu'est dark plagueis son
ancien maître stocker marquée par de
grandes blessures au visage
nous pouvons supposer qu'il était
déplacé dans la cuve pour ce faire
guérir mais pourquoi palpatine sa jeune
nous aurait-il face à lui alors qu'il
aurait tenté de le tuer c'est pas
logique
nous pourrions donc sûrement écarté la
théorie de dark plagueis m'enfin bon
dark sidious n'est pas sensé non plus
apparaître dans le film mais c'est
peut-être lui ressemble réellement il
n'y a que lui qui porte une cape avec
une capuche dans les premiers star wars
d'ailleurs nous pouvons remarquer la
présence des soldats impériaux vraiment
très important car ces soldats sont là
pour protéger des personnages très
important alors s'il garde la chose qui
se cache dans l'accueil de bacta sait
qu'elle doit être très importante et il
se pourrait que cela soit snow knock
semble très vieux dans star wars 7 mai
la force le maintien en vie il est clair
que le côté obscur déforme le visage
mais ce n'est réellement blessé au
visage il se pourrait qu'il était plongé
dans cette cuve pour guérir un gros
mystère se cache ici on ne connaît rien
de ce look et le mystère commence
vraiment à peser nous cherchons toute
explication rationnelle pour connaître
son identité mais toujours rien et le
fait que pablo et réfuter cette théorie
nous fait perdre encore l'espoir de
connaître l'identité de celui-ci et même
scénaristiquement l'histoire de snk sera
forcément compté dans l'opus 8 ou 9
pourquoi on connaîtrait l'histoire de
snogard gwan en plus ce qui est un
spin-off complètement à part de star
wars 7
rien ne colle même la présence de
palpatine ont fait des caisses pour
l'apparition de dark vador mais si douce
non alors pourquoi il apparaîtrait
passons à la dernière théorie
alors oui il fallait bien que je crée
une théorie par moi même car les acteurs
et lucasfilm créative réfute toutes les
théories de cet opus a la base je
voulais parler la théorie que boba fett
serait le père de jean berceau mais
réfuté et aussi le fait que jean arceaux
serait la mère de ré mais réfutée par
l'actrice de jean et les théories sur
snow pareil donc bon mais la précédente
théorie est quand même possible faut pas
toujours faire confiance aux créateurs
mais revenons à notre théorie dans ces
sites génèrent somme ouvrait à la fin de
l'opus ainsi que la plupart des
personnages pourquoi et bien tout
simplement à cause du fait que nous
connaissons la suite de l'histoire star
wars et que tout va bien
l'étoile noire sera détruite ainsi que
l'étoile de la mort et que les sites
seront détruits
que pouvons-nous argumenté déjà le but
du film et que les rebelles à et voler
les plans de l'étoile noire afin
d'empêcher sa construction et la
détruire nous savons que l'étoile noire
sera construite et qu'elle fera pas mal
de victimes
puisqu'elle sera ensuite détruites par
l'udc et les rebelles
donc cela veut dire que la mission dans
laquelle est envoyé jean est vouée à
l'échec
de plus nous ne retrouverons pas jean
dans les star wars suivant à part si
elle devient un personnage précis ou
bien qu'elle aille se cacher pour vivre
comme une ermite c'est assez courant
dans star wars comme yoda ou obi wan si
ce n'est pas le cas cela voudrait dire
que jean mourra dans locus de même pour
les autres personnages du film à part
certains comme certainement galen marek
qui pourrait être leur san té ka et
malheureusement on peut s'attendre au
pire pour beaucoup de personnages dont
jean
qu'en pensez vous ça se trouve elle
pourrait être la meilleure
n'hésitez pas interagir via les
commentaires c'est important je vous
remercie de m'avoir écouté et il me
tarde que ce film sorte car ils attisent
vraiment ma curiosité que le lionheart
soit avec vous cet argot rock
non
oh